good morning Jones Wednesday I have to
admit this though everyone on Facebook
already knows yesterday I created a fan
page for dr. Manhattan's dong and I
became a fan of it you should become a
fan of lower Manhattan too dr.
Manhattan's dong is blue and six feet
long and it lights up the night too
terrible fright when Laurie Jupiter
wears her thong today I want to talk
about brain crack dr. Manhattan's dong
is a good example of brain crack you
have an idea you get it out as fast as
possible because otherwise your brain
becomes addicted to the idea of ideas
and you think oh my idea is so important
that I have to keep it in here until I
can execute it perfectly this is one of
the fundamental gifts that I believes a
Frank has given to the world there's a
link in the sidebar
Tuesday Frank's brain crack video in
which you can discover how much better
he always was than we are oh he's so
good and while I was able to get dr.
Manhattan's dongs fan page up and out of
my head as fast as possible that has not
been the case with all of my ideas and
it's pretty frustrating to recognize
that I am indeed addicted to braincraft
what do I do about it I can't do
anything about it and while it is
possible to my belief I do not have the
time or resources to get these ideas
into the real world it's just a
rationalization it does not seem like
that to me it seems like I definitely do
not have the time or resources to get
these ideas out into the real world so
what I'm going to do instead of actually
doing them is just share them with you
the only person who matters and having
ideas is the person who does the idea
and so all of these ideas which I'm
tired of thinking of as my ideas I just
want them to be ideas so I'm gonna share
with you some of the ideas that I simply
do not want to have anymore
please enjoy them take them at face
value and if you want to put some time
into doing this yourself please please
do it idea number one some kind of
charity slash nonprofit database that's
like match.com for charities and you
answer a bunch of survey questions and
you fill it all in and then you think
about the process a thing just says
these are the charities that are most
aligned with your interests give to
these charities so you don't have to
think about it and you can be a good
person more quickly
and with less effort idea number two I
think that we can all intrinsically
recognize that when someone over the age
of 80 dies it's not as much of a tragedy
when someone needs a 40 or 20 dies you
know natural order and all that stuff so
if I was kind of one of their to be a
Death Index that tells you not what the
leading cause of death is but with the
leading cause of people losing years of
their life is so this would of course
bump car accidents way up because car
accidents kill young people
and it would push heart disease and
cancer down because heart disease and
cancer kill old people I don't even know
if it would change the picture that much
but I think it's something that should
be done because I think that we should
be making decisions not just based on
how many people things are killing but
at what age the things are killing the
people I view number three uh but but
fires calm but fires calm is like an e
greeting card service except that you
send them not when it's someone's
birthday or they had a baby or something
but when you've been expecting them to
maybe get that proposal in you send them
a but fire which would basically be the
internet version of lighting a fire
under someone's ass the next idea is the
recipe kiosk which would basically be an
integration between a recipe database
and an inventory database at a
supermarket so you just walk up to it
you push the button of like what you
want like I want a healthy meal and then
it would be like vegetarian lasagna and
I'd be like okay vegetarian lasagna and
then it would show me the recipe and
will show me how easy is and then I
would say I'm feeding two people and
then I would tell me how many calories
are in that recipe and it would tell me
how much it would cost at the grocery
store and then I'd say yes I want that
recipe it print out the recipe along
with my grocery list and where all the
things are in the store so I don't have
to like search around I like this idea I
think that it would be great because I'm
always going to throw it so I'm like I
don't know what to get I don't know how
to make food next idea stuff on my cat
works really well so I figured stuff on
babies would work too babies aren't
pretty much just as cute as cats I think
that stuff on babies komlin do well if
anybody has babies and they like putting
stuff on their babies that is a domain
name I actually own so if you're
interested in developing this just let
me know I'm not saying that's all my
ideas it's possible that I have too much
brain crack to let go of it all at once
I can't quite go colter but it feels
good to have those out there and I hope
the jus nerdfighteria will also free
your brain of the brain crack the world
needs ideas but it doesn't need ideas
that are stuck inside your head so let
them free I'd love to see your brain
crack spilling out all over the comments
and video responses free yourself by